♪ ♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY" ON
A FRIDAY NIGHT.
OUR COLLEAGUE, SHANNON BREAM,
HAS BEEN PRETTY BUSY LATELY.
BUT SOMEHOW IN BETWEEN HER LIVE
COVERAGE OF UKRAINE AND HER
DAYTIME ANALYSIS OF THE
SUPREME COURT HEARINGS, SHE
MIGHT HAVE FOUND SOME TIME TO
MAKE A FANTASTIC NEW BOOK THAT
IS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
SEAN CAUGHT UP TO CALL AT ALL
ABOUT IT A LOOK.
>> FOX NEWS AT NIGHT HOST
SHANNON BREAM HAS A FASCINATING
NEW BOOK TAKING READERS ON A
JOURNEY THROUGH THE LIVES OF
BIBLICAL WOMEN DETAILING THEIR
HEROISM, THEIR SACRIFICES, AND
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN FAITH AND
FAMILY.
AND HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE, AUTHOR
OF "THE MOTHERS AND DAUGHTERS OF
THE BIBLE SPEAK."
IT IS ON Amazon.com PAIRED WE
WILL PUT A LINK ON Hannity.com
BETTER COLIC ON MY FRONT
SHANNON BREAM IS WITH THE SPIRIT
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> I LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING ON IN
UKRAINE AND YOU SEE THE VITAL
ROLE THAT WOMEN ARE PLAIN.
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY ARE TAKING THE
CHILDREN TO BOARD OUR COUNTRIES.
THEY ARE TAKING THE BRUNT OF
TAKING CARE OF THE FAMILY.
AND THE MEN ARE GOING BACK AND
FIGHTING.
IN WORLD WAR II, IT WAS VERY
SIMILAR STORY.
BUT IF IT WEREN'T FOR EVERYONE
ELSE, INCLUDING EVERY
ABLE-BODIED MAN AND WOMAN
WORKING IN FACTORIES AND
BUILDING AMMUNITIONS NEEDED IN
THE FIELD OF BATTLE, THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WIN.
AND AS THE SAME MOST LESSONS ARE
REINFORCED IN THIS BOOK.
>> THEY ARE.
WE SEE OVER TIME THAT WOMEN HAVE
BEEN CALLED TO STEP IN MANY
TIMES TO BE BRAVE, TO BE BOLD.
MEN THROUGHOUT THE BIBLE IS
ALSO, BUT WE SEE THE STRENGTH OF
MOTHERS AND OUR COMMITMENT TO
THEIR CHILDREN.
THE BOOK STARTS WITH THE STORY
OF THE MOTHER OF MOSES AND HER
DAUGHTER, MIRIAM, THEY ARE THE
MOTHER-DAUGHTER PAIR THAT KICK
US OFF.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT, SHE WAS A
WOMAN.
SHE WAS OPPRESSED.
THERE WAS AN ORDER THAT WENT OUT
THAT EVERY MOTHER WHO HAD A
BABY, IF IT WAS A BOY, IT
IMMEDIATELY HAD TO BE KILLED.
AND SHE SAID NO, SHE HAD NO
CHOICE AND CONTROL IN HER LIFE,
BUT SHE MADE THAT VERY BRAVE
CHOICE BUT SHE AND HER DAUGHTER
TOGETHER SAVED AND HAD MOSES ON
TAPE HE WAS ABLE TO GO ON TO A
DESTINY THAT CHANGE THE WORLD.
BECAUSE EXACTLY.
THE CRAZY THING IS HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THROWN INTO THE
RIVER TO BE KILLED, THE RIVER
NILE, THAT IS WHERE ALL THE BABY
BOYS WERE SUPPOSED TO GO, BUT
AFTER SHE HAD HIM FOR SOME
MONTHS, SHE SAID ALL RIGHT, I'VE
GOT TO HAVE FAITH.
SHE CREATED A MINI ARC FOR HIM,
A LITTLE WATERPROOF BEEN MUCH HE
PUT HIM IN.
AND SHE WAS THE ONE WHO STOOD
THERE ON THE BANKS AND WATCH TO
SEE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO MOSES.
AND IF THE DAUGHTER HELP BREAK
HAPPENED UPON HIM FOR THE BABY
CRYING -- WE ARE TOLD THAT IN
THE BIBLE SHE HAD GREAT
COMPASSION FOR HIM.
SO LITTLE MIRIAM RISKS HER LIFE,
STEPS UP, AND SAYS, BY THE WAY
COME IF YOU NEED A HEBREW WOMAN
TO NURSE HIM UNTIL YOU'RE READY
TO TAKE HIM INTO THE PALACE,
BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO ADOPT HIM,
I NOTICED THE WOMAN.
SO SHE WAS ABLE TO RUN HOME AND
TELL HER IT MOSES IS GOING TO
COME HOME TO US BUT SHE WAS ABLE
TO RACE AND FOR 2-3 YEARS BEFORE
HE WENT OFF TO THE PALACE.
AND HIS ULTIMATE DESTINY WAS TO
SAVE THE ENTIRE NATION OF
ISRAEL.
>> THE BOOK GOES INTO GREAT
DEPTH AND DETAIL ABOUT THE WOMEN
IN THE BIBLE.
ARE THERE A TOP THREE THAT COME
TO MIND THAT REALLY INSPIRED YOU
THE MOST?
>> OF COURSE THE STORY OF ABOUT
MOSES MOM, BUT AS THERE, WE
THINK ABOUT HER BEING IN THE
PERFECT PLACE AT THE PERFECT
TIME.
YOU KNOW THE FIRST THOUGHT, FOR
SUCH A TIME AS THIS, SHE WAS
TOLD WHEN SHE WAS STRUGGLING TO
BE COURAGEOUS IN THAT MOMENT
WHEN SHE HAD TO STEP UP AND TO
BE THEY WANT TO SAVE THE JEWISH
PEOPLE.
IF YOU DON'T DO THIS, SOMEBODY
ELSE WILL BE CALLED INTO ACTION.
BUT MAYBE FOR SUCH A TIME AS
THIS YOU ARE PUT THERE, AND SHE
WAS.
OF COURSE, MARY THE MOTHER OF.
IN THE NEW TESTAMENT -- LIKE
THESE MOTHERS IN UKRAINE, THEY
WERE ON THE RUN WHEN GOD CAME TO
HER AND TO JOSEPH IN A DREAM AND
SAID, YOU'VE GOT TO GO, RIGHT
NOW.
KING HEROD IS TRYING TO KILL
YOUR BABY.
I THINK ABOUT HER IN THIS
DUSTY -- GRABBING EVERYTHING IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT WITH A
TODDLER AND SETTING UP TRYING TO
FIND SAFETY AND ENDING UP IN A
STRANGE LAND WITH NO FAMILY AND
NO FRIENDS.
AND THAT IS WHAT THESE BRAVE
MOTHERS OF UKRAINE ARE MODELING
FOR US TO DO.
HE SEES THE PLATE AND THE
SUFFERING TODAY.
>> THE BOOK IS CALLED "THE
MOTHERS AND DAUGHTERS OF THE
BIBLE SPEAK: LESSONS ON FAITH
FROM NINE BIBLICAL FAMILIES."
IT IS IN BOOKSTORES AS
OF MARCH 29TH.
IT IS ON Amazon.com.
YOU CAN GET YOUR COPY NOW.
SHANNON, I KNOW YOU HAD A
GREAT -- THIS WILL BE A GREAT
BIG SELLER AS WELL PAIR THEY
GIVE FOR SHARING IT WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
AND CONGRATS, SHANNON COME ON
THE BOOK.
NEXT WEEK THERE WILL BE A
FOX NATION SPECIAL ON SHANNON'S
CALLED "THE MOTHER'S AND
DAUGHT